les gaz lacrymogènes des matches chocs
électriques de boucliers anti-émeutes
avaient pu tuer les gens avec tout ça
sont des âmes sécuritaire destiné à
mainteni langues
non aujourd'hui on maintient l'ordre de
100 tués ce sont des tasers il faut
tirer à quelle distance et de mettre mon
capitaine
toi manger président je suis un petit
peu cardiaque
tu es peloton n'est ce pas unifiés
théâtre qui lui dessus
attendez-vous surprise on mange bien pas
du tout une ethnie fier pour mon père et
du limousin
ils attendent la côte du n'importe quoi
on dirait la girafe qui sont belles les
patois mais ça c'est que nos deux sas
oman 64 à oui c'est ça voilà ces cinq
ans la france mon voix pour nous
protéger
une arme qui peut faire caca